so what I want to talk about today is is
it a broadly expressing yourself and
don't mean like how you express your
feelings in our but how do you express
the data analysis which to me is the
process we're kind of raw data comes in
one side understanding knowledge and
insight comes out the other so what I
want to talk about is a little bit of
acid justification so I really strongly
believe that if you're doing data
analysis regularly it's really important
that you learn how to program so talk a
little bit about that so how many of you
here are programmers that's pretty much
pretty much everyone how many of you
builds tools that other programmers use
and yeah few yeah okay it's interesting
so I think it's really important that
you program if you're a data analysis I
think it's a little it's a little
strange to me that when I talk to
statistics departments I don't need to
tell them that everyone should be
programming but when I come to a
computer science department I have to
make that pitch a little bit more and I
think it's the same way like
statisticians strongly believe that if
you're doing statistics and you're not a
statistician you're doing it wrong
similarly computer scientists believe if
you're programming and not a computer
scientist you're doing it wrong too it's
a little bit of a caricature so if
you're in a program why should you use R
as a programming language talk a little
bit about that and then talk about two
of the projects that I've been working
on iterations of two of the tools that
Michael mentioned deep liar which makes
it easier to express your data
manipulations and Gigi givers which
allows you to express a new class of
visualizations so Y program to me there
are three main benefits first of all
reproducibility it allows you to redo
the past and the present this is really
important for good science you have to
be able to recreate what you did and and
and the I really like the idea of
provenance that you can track your data
from creation to the final artifact that
causes someone influences someone to
make a decision now reproducibility is
about recreating the past and the
present Automation is about preparing
for the future in the present so
programming is really important because
as new data comes in as it does all the
time you need to be able to rerun your
existing analysis and you need to be
able to redo new analyses that are
closely based on existing analyses now
the final benefit of communication of
code and the one I think is most
underrated is that code is a vehicle of
communication now it's obviously a
vehicle of communication between you and
the computer but it's also a really
powerful tool of communication for
between you and other people and that's
because code is just text it's very very
easy to put code in an email to ask
someone else how to fix your problem or
to Google for the answer or to post your
problem on Stack Overflow this is a
really really important part of coding I
think it's fundamentally a community
process and this is particularly so for
our since many our programmers many our
users a very very task-oriented
they want to solve a specific problem
they don't want to learn the beauty and
the peril of programming they just want
to get their jobs done so being able to
quickly find an answer whether it's in a
book or on the web or on Stack Overflow
is really really important so if you're
going to program why use our and I think
to answer that question you need to
think about like what are the what are
the bottlenecks and the data analysis
process and I think there are three main
categories or two main categories first
of all you have to think about what you
want to do you're going to figure out
what the next step is then you need to
precisely describe it in such a way that
the computer can understand what you
want in other words you have to program
it and then finally the computer has to
go away and crunch some numbers and in
my experience when you're doing a data
analysis the biggest bottleneck is
cognitive you spend way more time
thinking about the problem then you do
actually computing on the problem and if
that's the bottleneck then you don't
want to choose a programming language
that's optimized for performance it
doesn't matter if you can do this Tinh
if you can do the computation 10 times
faster if the computation takes a second
and you have to spend a minute thinking
about it right you want a language you
want to pick a language it helps you
think about the probe
and that helps you express that in code
and I think IRAs is really well-suited
for that the other thing is when you're
doing a data analysis you need the tools
of data analysis of which I think there
are four main parts first of all what I
call data tidying or data wrangling this
is a little bit like data cleaning this
is but it's a bit simpler this is just
getting the data in a form that you can
work with so the arrows sort of goes
here but in reality it's actually you
know maybe all the way over here right
that's often that the hardest part of
any data analysis project is just
getting it into a form that you can work
with now once you've got it into your
statistical analysis your data analysis
environment you're going to iterate
between three main sets of tools so
tools of transformation which include
things like creating new variables that
are functions of existing variables like
creating a variable density from weight
and volume or it could involve simple a
book aggregations like groups and sums
grouping and sums you're also going to
use visualization with strengths of
visualizations I think a two-fold first
of all they're really useful because
they uncover the unexpected
visualizations can surprise you in
visualizations are also really helpful
to help you refine your questions
this is often another big part of the
data analysis process is just making
your question sufficiently precise that
you can answer it now visualization
surprised you but they fundamentally
don't scale because a human has to look
at every single visualization so to me
the compliment of visualization the
models by which I take very very broadly
to include all of statistical models and
machine learning and data mining but
basically whenever you can make a
question sufficiently precise that you
can answer with a handful of summary
statistics or a simple algorithm I think
of that as a model so models are great
because they scale very well it's always
it's almost always cheaper to buy more
computers than it is to buy more brains
but models fundamentally do not surprise
you a model is never going to tell some
tell you something that you did not
expect a linear model will never say
your data is nonlinear or you've missed
this in two
so visualization surprised you but they
don't scale models scale but they don't
surprise you so in any real analysis
you're going to iterate between these
tools many many many times and I think
are as a as a language as a community
for data analysis provides many of the
tools or all of the tools to take all of
these pieces of the problem now there
are lots of reasons not to use our of
course and I certainly don't claim that
our is the best programming language in
the world it is a very unique and quirky
language but I think it is very very
well-suited to its domain so the two
main drawbacks to are that people talk
about others that it's slow which is
true but when you evaluate it's slow as
a programming language but that that
shouldn't be what you care about you
shouldn't be trying to optimize the
speed of your programming language you
should be trying to optimize the speed
of your data analysis the other thing is
that that R has always really been
designed as a language to glue together
other high performance languages it was
originally designed to glue together
command-line Fortran and C scripts so
many of the computational bottlenecks
and our have already been rewritten in
high-performance languages and our
provides tools to make it very very easy
to connect today as well the other
downside of our is that all of the data
must fit in memory is fundamentally an
interactive exploration environment and
to do that really all data must fit in
memory and people sort of talk about big
data pretty loosely now without I think
realizing a how big memory is these days
for example on Amazon ec2 you can get a
machine with 250 350 gigabytes of RAM
pretty easily and you can fit a hundred
million to a billion observations in
memory for $3 50 an hour so I think by
and large kind of companies have big
data problems but to answer a specific
question it's usually very easy to get
the data in memory through a combination
of simple subsetting or sampling or
aggregating
there's certainly lots of problems for
which this is not true but I think
probably 95 percent of problems have
people have far less than 100 million
observations so what I want to talk
about first
today is deep liar which is a tool to
make data transformation easier and I
want to talk about it and the context of
this little dataset I put together which
is from our package downloads in 2013
which comes from our cran mirror so here
I mean using the the deep layer package
I'm going to load this data set into are
calling it logs and then I'm going to
print it out now if you've ever used are
before and you've printed out a data
frame it has some rather interesting
defaults like it will print the first
10,000 rows for you typically looking at
10,000 rows of data on your screen is
not very informative so deep load is
just some simple thoughtful things like
only showing you ten rows by default it
allows you to see the data get some idea
of what's going on but it's not going to
overwhelm you with detail now as you
start to use bigger and bigger data it
starts to get really really helpful to
put comment commas in places so here we
can see there's around 23 million rows
of data here so this represents the 23
million packages that were downloaded
from our mirror in 2013 now this isn't
big data this is data that fits easily
in memory but it's still 1.6 gigabytes
so that's a reasonable that's hopefully
by anyone's definition that's a
reasonable amount of data and the goal
of deep liar is to tackle both sides of
this bottleneck to make it easier to
think about the data analysis think
about the data manipulation and what you
can do what you should do and then to
make it faster to actually do it so the
key insight there was to making the
cognitive bottleneck smaller is that by
and large is only really a few key data
manipulation verbs that you need for
almost all problems and they're the same
regardless of whether data moves so to
me there's five key verbs for
manipulating a single table of data so
select where you're picking a subset of
variables of interest filter we are
picking a subset of rows of interest
mutate we add new columns that are
functions of existing columns summarize
we reduce multiple numbers down to a
single number and a range where you
change the order of the rows so one
thing I think is interesting about this
is that it's easy to think of a data
frame or a table as a symmetric matrix
but that's really not the case data
frames are fundamentally not symmetric
you have variables in the rows
observations on the columns and so the
operations are going to the most
important operations are going to work
on rows and columns differently now
along with these verbs you need some
kind of a adjective which is the group
by so many of these things you want to
do by group you want to do summaries by
group you want to do transformations by
group you want to do subsets by group
and I'll show you some of these examples
shortly so what I'm going to do is a
little and what I want to do is find out
how many packages or what packages are
most frequently downloaded so first of
all I'm going to group the logs by the
package variable so I'm creating
something that represents so I'm
basically saying I want the unit of
analysis of this data set to be the
package next I'm going to summarize that
so this is a grouped object so this
means I want to summarize it by package
how do I want to summarize that well I
want to do that
by counting the number of observations
in each group and then finally I'm going
to range it and descending order and
then I'm going to take the first 20 so
I'm going to run this code live
hopefully and make that little bigger so
you can read it so I've loaded the data
in already because that takes about a
minute unfortunately one of the the
current bottlenecks and I was just
getting the data in can take a while and
now I'm going to run through those lines
of code and I'm using this function
system dot time just to show
you about how long each of these things
take and so all up doing this kind of
group summary on 20 million observations
takes about two seconds so this is this
is very much an interactive speed you
can iterate typically the first summary
that you do is not going to be the right
one you need to be able to rapidly
change your mind try out other things
and if we can run this code just to see
what it returns and hopefully it doesn't
seem too self-serving okay so one of the
things about the design of plier is that
it's very functional the goal is that we
have lots of little functions each
function does one thing it does it well
it takes inputs in the standard way it
never modifies anything in place it's
always going to return a new output so
the downside of that is when you're
writing sequences of operations you
either have to sort of write a lot of
intermediate variables or you have to
write things stat you have to miss
things read deeply in parentheses so one
thing I sort of discovered or invented
is this operation in are the in fix
function % dot % and what this basically
does is sort of a language manipulation
it takes an operation like this and it
turns into an operation like this so
what it allows us to do instead of
expressing nested operations it allows
us to write them from left to right so
here is the same code I showed you
before but written using this percent of
percent which is rather like the pipe
operator in F sharp so we take the logs
we group it by packages we summarize it
creating a new variable called in which
is a count of all of the the the number
of observations in each group we arrange
it in descending order of N and then we
take the top 20 observations so the goal
is to create something that we can read
very naturally that should make it
easier for us to write the code and when
we come back to our code months later
you can still look at it and understand
what the heck you're thinking
and so just to illustrate that that
actually works I can run that and we
have to repeat all those operations
again takes about two seconds and we see
the top 20 downloaded packages yes
harder because you know we're having an
immediate variable seconds yes yes
definitely
when I kind of discovered I could do
this I was a little uncertain as to
whether people would like this idea or
not because that the disadvantage of
this code is that there's quite a lot of
magic going on behind the scenes it's
actually kind of creating a call that
has everything nested pretty deep and it
does make debugging a pain a little more
painful but you certainly can if you if
you prefer to have easier to bugging and
you can certainly write it like this and
Mike yeah this one what I the way I
normally work is they do something like
this like you know so I write this and I
check that it works and then once I've
checked that that line works
I write the next line and once I verify
that that line works I write the next
line so I don't imagine by and large
people writing big blocks of code like
this and then running it and then well
actually I do I do very much imagine
people doing that because my experience
teaching people are is that that that's
the biggest problem if you say go and
write a function what people do is they
write a function it does everything and
then they run it and it doesn't work and
there's 15 possible places where there's
an error and it's very hard to debug so
any analysis is an R is going to be very
very iterative you're going to play
around with things on the command line
you're going to try things out and
iterate your way to a solution rather
than writing one big expression now of
course there's other you you're
typically not doing data analysis with
just one table of data you've got
multiple tables and the verbs here
basically come pretty direct
from SQL relational algebra the most you
for most useful are the left for join
the inner join which most people know
about the other two that are really
useful of the semi join and the anti
join the semi join but these joins are
kind of like filters they don't add any
new columns they just restrict the rows
based on whether they match or not don't
match and the in the other table as well
as the cognitive side deep layer aims to
make the computational side more
efficient as well for local data frames
it doesn't do anything particularly
magical it just uses some efficient C++
code to avoid some of the many copies
that are makes generally when you're
working with data one cool thing that we
do however is we have implemented a
little miniature evaluator for our
expressions of the nature that you
commonly see in subsetting and mutating
operations which is usually using
logical comparison or using summary
functions like mean or men and that
allows us when we're summarizing over
thousands or tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of groups to or to
avoid the overhead of our D our function
call this is our work joint done with
Romain Francois who is a vastly superior
C++ programmer to me and all of this
stuff is just so obviously trivially
paralyzed able you can always split up
the data and have different threads
working on different pieces at the same
time and we're currently working on
exploiting that so my sort of vision is
with one of these big ec2 instances
you've got you know 300 gigabytes of RAM
you've got 32 cause you should be able
to do an interactive exploration with
data on a hundred million to a billion
rows so compared to if you've used
player before for some operations apply
it so deep layer is generally a hundred
to 10,000 times faster than player so
I've had some gratifying tweets of
people who say they switch reply to D
player and their card win from taking 3
hours to run to taking 2 seconds which
is more of a test
mentor how bad player was then the
testament to how good d player was but
the goal of player was always to be more
about the cognitive side than the
computational side now the other thing
that's really important when you start
working with bigger data sets is that
you don't want to move the data around
the data is big and it's expensive to
move around so instead of moving the
data to where the computation is you
want to send the computation to where
the data is and so D player has this
idea of a back end trying to abstract
over the idea of a table of data we've
got rows and columns which basically
looks the same regardless of what system
you're using to store it so as well as
some local sources like a data frame and
a data table and a sort of experimental
data cube you can also work with tables
that are stored in a relational database
or things that are kind of like
relational databases but aren't quite
like Google's bigquery so one thing I
think that that's really interesting
with many of the platforms for storing
big data they by and large standardizing
on SQL as a language for getting that
data out and if you wanted to make a bit
on what languages people are still using
in 50 years time to do data analysis I
would bet you a lot of money that will
still be using SQL just only slightly
horrifying
so what deep layer does is it allows you
to keep expressing what you want and are
and it's going to translate to SQL code
for you so the goal here is not so that
you don't have to understand how
databases work or how you write or how
SQL works but allow it the goal is to
avoid some of the cognitive overhead of
switching between R and SQL and I think
the cognitive over here is by and large
not because the languages are so
different but because they're so similar
but with some very subtle distinction
which creates bugs that are very painful
to to figure out so I'm going to show
you a live example with a slightly
different data set here we're looking at
the flight delay data set or a subset of
that called H flights
not short for Headley flights but
Houston flights so if we look at this we
print this out and tells us this data
set is coming from Postgres this is a
data set that lives in a database and
we're going to just interact with it
like we can interact with any other data
source and r-and-d player is going to
automatically generate the SQL to talk
to it for us so you can see again it's
about two hundred thousand rows which is
not particularly big but this
illustrates talking to databases so I'm
going to do an operation which i think
is very natural but it's actually quite
hard to express in SQL I'm going to take
this data base I'm going to group it by
the tail number or so I'm going to group
which is the unique identifier for each
plane something the unit of analysis is
going to be the plane I am going to
mutate it I'm going to add a new column
called rank where I'm just ranking the
the flights made by each plane based on
how much they were delayed and then in
my final result I am just going to show
the three variables the tail number the
arrivals of delay in the rank so this is
something that I think is fairly natural
to Express so I'm going to run that and
it executes instantly because it doesn't
do anything the key here is to be as
lazy as possible it's not going to fetch
any data and until I explicitly ask for
it and if you can look at this object
and you can see that there's a SQL query
there it uses window functions which are
extension in SQL 2003 which allow you to
express some sort of sum some of the
things that's very natural to express in
a vectorized programming language like
our button SQL we can also do lots of
although our standard SQL things we can
ask
we might be worried this is going to
take a really long time to execute so we
could ask Postgres to explain its query
plan and if you understood post query
plans you could look at this and tell me
how long it's going to take but I don't
know anything about that so I'm just
going to run it I know a little bit
about it but not that much
so you can see here I've just typed in
it's going to print it out it's going to
print out the first ten rows which
unfortunately are not very interesting
because they seem to be possibly a bug
in the code or possibly we have some
planes without tail numbers and no
arrival delays and we've got some a
problem with the rank but the goal here
is that deplane never does any work
until you force it to ask for the data
always tries to do the minimum amount
possible working in concert with the
database
here's another operation this is a group
that was a grouped transformation a
grouped mutate this one is a grouped
filter so again we take the data set we
group it by the tail number a unit of
analysis as the plane we're going to
filter it so that the arrival direct
delay equals the maximum arrival delay
so for each flight we've reached plane
we're going to find the flight that was
most delayed and then I'm just going to
show you the tail number and the arrival
delay or maybe we should actually we
could add in that and look at the I'll
just look at the data set again just to
make sure I remember the variable names
origin mm dist yeah okay so let's run
that again it doesn't do anything that's
being lazy the SQL it generates now is
even more complicated because of the way
that window functions work you have to
use a wrap everything in a sub query but
so this is this is an operation that I
think that's very very natural right I
can explain it to you for every plane
give me the flight that was most delayed
and if you knew is skew L you could
probably eventually iterate your way to
this maybe with a little bit of googling
and using of Stack Overflow but you
would get there in the end but here deep
layer kind of wraps it around so you
express something that's natural in a
data analysis and it's my problem to
convert that into useful SQL not yours
again we can explain
at or we could run it and see the first
ten rows which again takes a few seconds
to run so generally if you for anything
you can fit in memory that's going to be
orders of magnitude faster than using a
database since it has to go to disk you
can see all of these flights left George
Bush International and you can see the
worst delays or are these are all in
minutes right so 300 minutes that's
almost a five-hour delay by and large
you don't see many delays higher than
that because airlines just cancel highly
delayed flights otherwise their flight
delays statistics look very bad so as
with any kind of real data where someone
cares about some of these numbers
there's gaming that goes on there's
supports or some interesting stuff like
if you take these tail numbers and match
it up with the FAA database of tail
numbers there's like a surprisingly high
number of hot-air balloons that travel
more than 300 miles an hour and serve
commercial air traffic in the United
States so I mean one of the things when
you're working with data is you can
basically never trust the raw data and
you always want to be looking for these
these strange behaviors so if you want
to learn more about deep layer you can
Google for it there is a github page as
a package on crane you can use it and
there's a number of vignettes that go
into more detail about the underlying
principles the other project I wanted to
talk about today is called Gigi vis this
is joint work with Winston Cheng this is
tackling the visualization problem and
is aimed kind of squarely in the
cognitive space so the goal of Gigi vers
the three goals so first is you want to
be able to describe visualizations
declaratively like you do in ggplot2 the
graphics should be on the web so of the
web not just on the web but of the web
it's going to produce things that are
fundamentally web graphics as HTML CSS
JavaScript the the sort of the goal is
that you know you can do a fantastic
visualization and you can show it to
your boss or your advisor on their iPad
and they're like amazed at how awesome
you are
and it's also built out of reactive
components reactive in the sense of
functional reactive programming which
allows a declarative specification of
interactive and dynamic behavior which
is easier to show you as I will shortly
than it is to describe so as I said it's
aimed thoroughly and this cognitive
domain
my feeling is by and large the visual
Big Data is not a visualization problem
big data is a modeling and summarization
problem which you then visualize there's
only so many pixels on your screen
you're going to have far more data
points than you do have pixels so when
you're thinking about visualizing large
data sets you have to think about how
can i summarize this down to something
useful that I can gain insight from with
just a few million pixels I have on my
computer so I'm going to show you this
with a little demo and I'm going to be
using again some data from the cran
downloads this time I'm going to group
it by date and I'm going to summarize it
to count the number of packages on each
day and also the number of distinct IP
addresses so in some in some way this is
like the number of packages and how many
people downloaded those packages so we
run that takes a couple of seconds to
compute and then I'm going to start
doing some plots so the main
visualization function is called cuba's
just call it visualization and you give
it a data set the data sets the first
thing because that's the most important
component of any visualization then you
tell it what should what variable should
go on the x-axis and what variable
should go on the y-axis so we have date
on the x-axis and the number of
downloads on the y-axis and because
we've specified two variables we're
going to get a scatter plot which isn't
very useful here so what I'm going to do
next is I'm going to say I don't want to
scatter plot I'm going to override the
default choice I'm going to use a line
plot so you can drag this out and if we
pop this out into another window you'll
see it just opens up in Chrome this is
just
some HTML some CSS some JavaScript and
if you look at this if you're familiar
at all with Vega which is a declarative
Splott specification by jiff here we're
using Vega as the rendering system so
we're just sending this declarative JSON
to the browser and the browser is going
to render there for us so this is a plot
of the number of packages downloaded
each day what's going to the biggest
what's the pattern that jumps out most
clearly here weekends right so fewer
packages download on the weekend which
is telling you something not terribly
surprising and that's most people use
our for work not for fun well though
there still are a lot of downloads on
the weekends one interesting thing we've
seen with some other data is that on the
weekend it tends to be slightly higher
proportion of max during the download
then during the week which is I think a
little interesting so instead of showing
the number of downloads per day we could
show our approximation for the number of
people downloading in it so this is
interesting like when we look at the
number of people downloading the pattern
is much much much more regular I'm not
sure why that's the case but what we
could do is look at the average number
of packages downloaded per person and
this just sort of illustrates that when
you're doing a visualization you want to
be able to do inline transformations I
want to look at the number of packages
divided by the number of IP addresses
and so there's some interesting
variability some of these spikes I can
explain I think this one here and this
one represent new releases of are so
when you download a new version of are
you have to download all of your
packages again I have no explanation for
these other spikes these ones are
particularly interesting like the first
of September it may be that these
represent like big online our course
online courses start
because typically if you download even
if you download like ggplot2 you have to
download about 30 other packages that it
depends on so visualizations are a very
iterative process if we go back to this
original plot looking at the so if we go
back to the yeah this plot of looking at
the number of IP addresses per day
unique IP addresses today once you've
seen this week in pattern we're probably
not that interested in it we might be
more interested in what's the long-term
trend and package downloads so we might
want to add a smooth line overlaying it
so here I'm just providing a victor I'm
saying I want both lines and a smooth
overall fit and it's going to add a
Louis curve to the plot now of course we
never you add a smooth to a plot or
whenever I add a smooth to apply them
always like well that's not the right
amount of smoothing so I'm going to show
you a slightly more specific way of
writing that exact that plot and then
show you how you can control the amount
of smoothing so here I'm using a
slightly fuller specification Q versus a
little bit magical it tries to give some
things for you
g-give is a little bit more explicit we
say the data we want is this downloads
data set the visual properties put date
on the x-axis but the number of IP
addresses on the y-axis add a layer of
lines and add a smooth layer on top of
that now we can control the amount of
smoothness using the spanned parameter
so I could set the span to point nine
span as a number approximately between
zero and one I could make a point eight
run that again well that's not Wiggly
enough I could make that point seven
right parameter space exploration by
changing a number and rerun in code
is obviously really really painful so
what I'm going to do is define a new
object which represents a slider so this
is a slider that goes from point one to
one and it's going to start at point
five and then in my plot I'm going to
say
make the span of the smoother map it to
the slider and when I do that pop this
out so it's a little easier to see when
I do that I get a slider and as I drag
the slider I can control how Wiggly that
smoother is so you'll notice here
there's no here we've got some the plot
update is a respond a response to the
slider but we don't have any we haven't
written so many explicit observers to
say update the plot when the slider
changes yep yeah so I should mention if
we pop this out you'll notice this URL
is a local webserver so every time I
drag this it asks our to recompute the
smoother so this is designed
fundamentally to have and for every
visualization you have an instance of
are running in the backend now that I
give you the New York Times that would
clearly be an awful idea right you need
to have hundreds of thousands of our
instances running in the background
but for the for our goal which is to
make exploratory data analysis easier
this is absolutely what we want because
you're only limited by what I can do and
that's not much of a limitation when it
comes to statistical modeling so I'm
going to close that down and of course
you know you can easily map pretty much
any other HTML input components so this
is a pretty lame one but you can just
see I'm changing the color of the line
and the system is intelligent enough
that when I change the color of the line
it's not going to ask our to recompute
that line and knows the color is
independent of the computation
so so Gigi vis is built on this this
idea of reactive components so
components which don't just have a
single value that's fixed fixed in time
but have values that change over time
that fundamentally reacted and the thing
that's neat about building on top of
this reactive framework is that it
doesn't really matter why those values
are changing so rather than binding a
parameter to a control we could Behrendt
bind it to this thing
I called waggle which is just going to
animate values between point two and
point one so doing exactly the same
thing here I'm saying the span is just
this waggle component and now I have an
animation exploring the space now this
is kind of a not this is not a terribly
interesting example but the thing that's
neat about the framework is this
animation is just a stream of values
coming on and that's exactly the same as
if you've got streaming data with new
values coming on that this framework is
fundamentally reactive so that as your
data changes so too does your plot or
another source of reactivity is the
keyboard here I've bound the span to the
left and right arrow so as I push the
keys I can interactively experiment with
the smoothness yes is that not currently
so it's there that that's something that
is achievable within this framework we
just haven't implemented it yet so as
well as these binding simple controls or
simple streams of values to parameters
of the plot
we can also add slightly more higher
level interactions so for example in
this case I'm going to add a tooltip a
tooltip takes a callback function it's
given some data about the point under
the mouse and it returns some HTML and
which in this case is just going to be a
number so when we mouse over the point
you can see exactly how many ip's
downloaded packages on that day or
instead of a tooltip that works with
just a single value we can make a
tooltip that works with a brush in here
just showing the total number of IP
addresses under the brush which updates
as you move it although you'll see
there's some bugs and it currently
doesn't under unbrushed the point but so
GG vis is sort of has mostly been an
expert as so far as sort of a proof of
concept convincing me that a declarative
specification of a visualization plus
reactivity is like a grammar I think of
interactive graphics it allows us to
specify a very large variety of
interactions and when and when I mean it
allows us that kind of I mean it allows
you that I don't have to pre specify
every possible interaction you can come
up with new interactions that make sense
for your data so Gigi vis similarly if
you want to learn more you can Google
for it there is a github page there are
some vignettes that describe more about
the underlying philosophy more about how
the reactivity works at a fairly deep
level and it's it is uh it's it's usable
but the demo I just showed you was
carefully constructed to make it look as
impressive as possible and so there are
currently a lot of little little things
that make a little bit frustrating to
use but we're working very hard to make
those not such a problem so in
conclusion I think it's really important
when you're thinking about how can you
make better tools for data analysis
better tools to understand data you
think about all of the bottlenecks both
computational and cognitive you have to
make tools that make it easier to think
about a problem make it easier
grab that problem programmatically and
then make it easier to compute with it
and certainly in my experience the
biggest bottleneck is cognitive you
spend way more time thinking about the
problem than computing on it which means
by and large that research if it should
be focused on making it easier think
about data analysis not making easy to
do it computationally so you want tools
that help you define the problem make it
make it easier to express your ideas
about how to solve the problem and I
think R is really well-suited for this
instead of a host language for
developing domain-specific languages so
data analysis in many ways is sort of a
combination of a sequence of
domain-specific languages you want a
domain-specific language to express how
to get your data out of whatever format
it's in and are you want a
domain-specific language to express data
manipulation you want one for
visualization and then you want one to
describe your models and then the rest
of the programming language just sort of
helps you do things like for loops where
you know well I've got six variables I'm
going to explore them all the same way
I'm going to write a for loop to do that
rather than copying and pasting my code
multiple times so if you'd like to get a
copy of the slides which I presume I'll
also give to Michael so you can put them
on the website but you can download them
from this URL here thank
so you started out with this idea that
programming is the right way to interact
with these systems I and I just want to
push it on a little bit because I think
there's a little bit of a tension
between that claim and this conclusion
about domain-specific languages in the
sense that what you're doing is creating
a small scale ways of interacting with
visualization for example in juju does
that don't require programming work in
deep wire that are much closer to
natural language semantics in some sense
these seem like perfect candidates for
taking these and saying okay now let's
put a natural language semantics on top
of that and we'll just face up or let's
put a click-and-drag semantics on this
you can just add your tooltip by
clicking the tooltip like yeah why not
do that so I think this - I think
there's two reasons not to do that so
the first one is these tools are
fantastic like the most common 80% of
tasks the other 20% of tasks don't
require five tools to solve them they
require like 500 different tools and if
you're like locked into this box so you
can only express the most common 80% of
operations that means like you're always
uses lots of things you can't do because
you need to do some special case but
also I think it the advantage of
embedding everything in a programming
language is you never like limited by
what I think universe have locked into
an environment where you can only do
what Hedley thinks is the right thing to
do you can always break out of that and
do what you think is the right thing
what someone else does you can integrate
this with other people's code I think
also if you are even if you were to
create a like a GUI or some kind of nice
interface around this it can make sense
to develop the language first and it is
I think it's like developing to me like
developing the language is the sort of
the easy part then developing a toolkit
to express that that that's that's
another hard problem and if you then
later on discover oh I've actually
missed a really important part and
you've got to totally rethink your
toolkit and then again like having this
I guess so you are arguing a natural
language you still have sort of you you
always want text on the end right and
whether that's like an embedded DSL or
an external DSL I think that that sort
of it doesn't really matter but having
embedded in a programming language is so
important to break out of that box when
you need to I was just going here with
us for a long term where it is shiny and
ggplot2 in G G vis where how are they
going to sort of fit into each other
eventually sorry I should have mentioned
that
so G G versus using shiny under the hood
all of the reactivity comes from but
whenever you create a plot whenever you
create an interactive plot that's
actually a shiny web application running
behind the scenes in terms of GG versus
GG plot and in some ways the
complementary like GG versus aimed
squarely to pop to is aimed squarely at
print graphics GG versus aimed a web
graphics if you want to make a PDF or a
printout or a book right having an
interactive something doesn't matter you
want just something you can easily get
into a PDF and and do what you want with
that that's it like there's only one of
me and I can't like work simultaneously
on ggplot2 and GG versa make progress on
both so lately GG vers as sort of a
ggplot has been rather fallow and I
think what we're going to do in the near
future is basically say ggplot2 is now
in maintenance mode we'll fix major bugs
will accept poor requests but we're not
going to do any active development one
thing that's really challenging with
ggplot2 now is that there's such a large
community of people using it that there
are well-known bugs that people have
come up with workarounds for that if I
was to fix the original bug would break
all of the workarounds and so the net
effect of fixing a bug is actually to
break more code than not fixing it and
the sort of ties in a little bit genuine
for the tooling around making
reproducible code and our that keeps
running that we're working on and in
other ways a little bit of that on this
notion of like what you want to do with
a PDF
one web graphics you could imagine the
future of science and some should not be
PDFs yes right we should be creating
papers that have these graphics that I
can interact with yeah you can imagine
creating some I know you shuddered at
this notion but think about like the
managed services for Roku problem you
know our Roku or whatever yeah where I
can specify these things and now part of
my my research result or whatever I'm
doing for my company gets hosted by the
sites yeah and then anyone else who
looks at it can actually play with it go
down to the patio duck calls
I feel like bats end up being working
good allow allow me to fork that is that
they are good myself
yeah why are you why are needs stopping
it yeah I would say I mean PDFs
generally like the past right an
interactive web stuff is the future I
don't think you'd argue with me that
interactive hTML is what that's going to
be right it's not going to be Wolfram's
computational data format for example
the other thing that that the other
thing that I've been working on which is
sort of similar to this as I've been
writing a book which like and if I can
connect the internet quickly try and
those look very visitor II but I've been
writing a book in the open and I'm
writing it an hour markdown which you
can render into markdown which gets
rendered into HTML and the book is just
a github repo it's it's it's all
published on the website and has an edit
this page button much like a wiki but
instead of editing the page directly it
edit it and github and then when you
click Save it submits a pull request to
me so then I can review the pull request
and integrate that in that that's
firstly like a really fantastic like
collaborative writing environment and I
think it used to be a wiki and such as
since I switched to the system where I
review if we change people actually
submit more changes because they know
I'm going to look at it the other piece
of technology that's really cool is in
that is using Travis which is a
continuous integration system so any
time a change gets pushed to github
everything gets all of the code gets
rerun
all of the HTML gets regenerated and
pushed to the book website and we are
certainly imagining a future where
you're not just pushing static graphics
but you're somehow kind of pushing the
live interaction there as well
and then that sort of like thinking
about being able to write books which
have interactive components which people
can play with and all that kind of stuff
is really really exciting
I'm gonna give I played around a lot
with my phone you know wondering if you
can contrast like say our studio and I
play around my understandings ipython
the fungal black back-end you can
imagine yeah so the iPod is this a
notebook interface where you have cells
input an output and you can intermingle
rich text and you're colored this or the
equivalent in the our community so so
y-you can put an art back into ipython
by and larger thought that our community
uses is this tool call our markdown
which let me just quickly pull up
so our markdown is a similar idea so you
can enter mingle bridge text written and
markdown with our code when you execute
the document the our code is run and the
environment the the code and texture
that the resultant takes two interleaved
so the main difference is with the serve
that the ipython philosophy is you have
one file which contains the code and the
results of running that code in the our
markdown philosophy you have one code
one file that's the input which contains
the code and then you have one file
which is the output so the advantage of
the ipython approach is that you've got
one file to email but for someone to
read that they need to use a special
viewer because the documents just a JSON
data structure the advantage of the are
markdown approach is you can just some
email someone an HTML file or a PDF but
then they can't going to run the code
and such an easy way as as ipython so I
think like our markdown plus an IDE is
effectively equivalent and expressive
powered like a notebook where it gives
you very similar tools but I think
that's a really interesting space to
explore and generally like the different
ways of intermingling documentation or
text and code to explain things as that
we're just still starting to see
what the different approaches are and
what a what's going to went out a slayer
that you could set their level of
excluding with and what it was this
scope for this kind of interact you sort
of playing into grab and you have a drop
box at like a global variable or
multiple of these that we updated many
excelling these drop box though there
was some good updated look so that sort
of like sequence of drop boxes we each
felt progressively filters is not
something you could do that easily I've
showed you what what I showed you was
kind of the the very concise format we
you're using kind of components that
we've built like the you know I'm using
components like the the drop down or the
slider you could also write your own
components using any HTML right if you
wanted a date picker you could write an
HTML date picker you gonna have to know
some HTML and JavaScript if you want to
do that and cook it up to an hour object
that represents that so if you if you
know a little bit about HTML you can add
some of these structures some of them
you can do if you write a shiny app and
just use our existing things otherwise
you are a little bit constrained with
what kind of fundamental input elements
we've written already kind of discussed
before that like he bugging is very hot
in this kind of like discarding material
it was your vision that I mean is it
possible to also have a variable I mean
if you're doing this multiple piping of
data together yeah that kind of like you
could tell the user immediately that if
any of these like oh is fading or
something yeah I think there's a lot of
scarf ability bugging tools another
problem you can imagine now you've got a
graphic that's dynamically changing over
time and at some point it breaks like
that is going to be an incredibly
frustrating debugging experience and I
don't think there's still a lot of
thinking to do with what with what bit
of tools you could come up with one
thing that I can imagine very easy
Lee is the sort of some of the the Brett
Victor idea so in maybe when you're
typing this and I push into you could
imagine getting a little preview that
shows the first few rows and so I could
check immediately have I done the right
thing or not I think that that that
feedback loop we find out as quickly as
possible have I done the right thing or
not is really really important and since
you know I'm working with the people
writing the IDE there's a lot of scope
to add that kind of interaction
programming it I didn't he just because
his provenance hell they're a result
came from certainly and it seems like
this model to kind of you know you
create a graphic and then publish it and
publish its a web around someone goes
can plays with it was like that one in
the graphic you know is now disconnected
from the code that move it just usually
doesn't have anything where you know
grab it sort of knows about how it got
created you can tell is August
this is not something we've thought
about I think generally our model is if
you did one people and to understand how
it was created you would also publish
the source code along with it I mean one
one thing we've thought about is also
the ability to kind of publish an
interactive graphic by pre-rendering a
number of the computation so it doesn't
have to hit our every time it just
stores everything in the Jason we're the
envy at least you'd have the data stored
and the document even if you wouldn't
have all of the calculations I think
there's a similar like with
reproducibility there's only ever so
much you can reproduce right you can
reproduce
the actions that someone take talk but
it's very very you can't like reproduce
their thought process which led to those
actions which you could then reproduce
data analysis with a new data set right
so there's this sort of always
limitations and like will kind keep
pushing it as far as we can but yeah
again I think that that's just not like
that that sort of more the notebook
style which is not the way that we've
been thinking currently but that's a
certainly a valid way to do it and I'd
think and I would imagine it would
wouldn't be too hard to hook up ipython
so you could have like jeevers graphics
they would work interactively in the
notebook as well so you serve this claim
I agree with that you want to take
advantage of the things that people are
good at computation fact that difference
the proximity of the languages
description to you how I think about
your problem and if this is the case
no and you look at what people are
learning first what are there are poems
people start scripting you're not
looking at all be honest you're looking
at with HTML and JavaScript which is
where like many many people start yeah
and I wonder what this would look like
if you looked it around and said let's
take these same verse here and make
JavaScript as you know the best language
ever make it massively yeah data
parallel in these same ways stand by
by you know embedding the script and
then anything that someone wants to do
on the visualization side there's
already very rich yeah visual come out
of the JavaScript yes I mean I think
your your sort of your your question is
like why use our as a home for data
analysis as opposed to JavaScript in
some sense yeah yeah I mean I I agree
and I think yeah I think it's a two main
contributions of this work and that
first is that intellectual framework
like these are the five verbs and if you
wanted to go
implement a JavaScript phone you can use
those ideas and if you do that that's
like success for me as a researcher
right that I found something that's
useful but for me to go and do that they
don't have to go and learn JavaScript
right so it's all the sort of like like
relative costs
I think Java starters I think that would
make they could make a more approachable
data analysis platform for many people
have learned JavaScript already on the
other hand it's going to make but the
thing that javascript is weakest in is
the the modeling side so if you're going
to if you're going to be in JavaScript
in well you can do the visualization and
transformation but now you're also going
to implement a whole lot of statistical
models and then that that's basically
how it is in every language right every
language provides some of the pieces and
you have to do a whole lot of work to
provide the final one you know I've done
a lot of work to date building these
pieces an hour and seems to lead to
throw it away just because lots of
people know JavaScript a JavaScript is
interesting though because I think but
it's very very similar in many ways both
as a programming language that's
lexically scoped and if you there's a
lot of interest in functional
programming now and also as sort of a
community where like most JavaScript
code is crap and most our code is really
bad and you know there's there's like
like Douglas yeah that Douglas Crockford
is JavaScript the good part is sort of
like are the good parts as well
you